and let me ask you this how long you've
been Jamaican no not - was it called the
one the guys that are weird the
vegetarian vegan is the vegan yet the
bitchin you will not eaten any cut in
any kind of service like if I went let's
go Korean barbecue you can do it no but
I went with some friends the other day
and uh like that it was like a chicken
place it was very tempting it was yeah
it's very tempting yeah yeah I would
never do that to you
what made you a vegan or choose to be a
vegan I just like when I was a kid like
I KFC right was [ __ ] delicious it was
amazing
just chicken period and then some way
along the line like and it's like when
your kid you want when you like when you
it was a special thing KFC was like we
get in KFC because how broke we were
churches chicken yeah when I grow up I'm
just gonna have when I have my money I'm
gonna suck gonna have KFC and then and I
did that and I said this doesn't taste
the same
yeah and then you know and it wasn't the
ingredients that they changed the actual
chicken though but they have to make so
much meat for so many people like all
these restaurants around here they get
them fooled they cheat they put hormones
and stuff and [ __ ] it's not healthy yeah
I'm somebody even sent me this thing on
my phone there's this inside a chicken
guy right yeah who he's whistle blowing
on the chicken Department and he's like
he's like he takes the reporter into the
chicken coop and he's like this is what
they call free-range chicken there's no
cages they're all in here but there's
like a thousand chickens in this room
yeah and that's how they skirt the law
and then they they don't call the the
growth hormones or the whatever they
inject or feed it to animals anymore
what they what the FDA says they can't
use they call it something
but they still feed the chickens the
same have found a way to skirt and then
they're the ones that that FDA sends
them a checklist of things that they
have to comply with and they're the ones
that fill it out they don't come down
then check it out
well there's a bogus organization anyway
so then they do it and then it's like
it's like us great in our own papers yet
what we're going to give ourselves like
I want I want I don't want to you don't
have to stop like sometimes if you don't
eat it as much as you do then that's
fine I got would never tell anybody to
just stop well now you do you used to
hate them I just I want to be friends
with the animals all of them even the
chickens yeah I want to be friends and
what life to live they have every right
to live there's nothing nothing even
sways his anything that he does anymore
we watched a documentary called at the
fork I mean it was chicken Wow he
watched it yeah he at that moment he
feels you know sympathetic to the
animals after that just exact moment but
it's so quick as soon as the documentary
is over me a bad person though you know
does that make me a bad person no not at
all are you a vegetarian no I just don't
eat [ __ ] out of meat last night what
kind of meat do I eat cow no but I'm
very careful about like where I yet if I
do eat beef where the beef comes will
that shabu-shabu play something that was
the freshest place
I do make exceptions like you know twice
or three times a month we go to Korean
food and you know I think that I don't
know where it comes from but if I have
to shop it myself
I'm very much I'm very aware of you know
making sure that she's good about the
eggs they have to be free like real
free-range I'm good about the butter to
the butters is really good about yeah
but it's really hard to struggle for you
around
it's tough it's just tough period
because even when you're trying to be
healthy you don't know if these labels
are correct it's just tough man it's
just people trying to make money out
here yeah and it's so because we are
such a big country it's so hard to
regulate something that like in a
country like Norway they have everything
all the labels everybody Europe then you
can eat all you meat and not feel bad
yeah really yeah but it's easier to
operate in small and district like that
yeah yeah I mean let's it let's just say
this okay I'm not gonna stop just cried
I just cried I cried but I'm not gonna
stop you should it's here for the cow
you're good so you know I feel I just
want I want the world and God to know
that I feel right and I think that's
good enough alright we also just don't
utilize the whole animal here in the
United States like III make necklaces of
the chicken bones hopeful advice we do
an email answered questions okay
[Music]